tracy morgan's suffered a ten-year
campaign of harassment at the hands of
her stalker who was eventually jailed
for the attempted murder of another
woman her case resulted in law changes
but the relentless abuse caused her her
marriage her home and her health
psychological damage that was going on
is untold and it also has an impact in
every avenue of your life as much as you
don't want it to you lose control of
everything you're monitored you don't
know if you're going to die today you
don't know what's going to happen so you
have to be prepared every single day
every night
just in case the stalking protection
order is being hailed as a powerful new
tool that will stop suspects in their
tracks while an investigation is carried
out these are really groundbreaking
orders that the police will be able to
apply for to protect victims of stalking
but also to make sure that the
perpetrators are getting the treatment
programs and so on that they need to
break the cycle of abuse and stalking
the Sussex Police and crime Commissioner
knows what she's talking about
she was once stalked herself it's been
quite a traumatic period but it's given
me a greater understanding of what
victims go through and actually how
vital things like these stalking
protection orders are going to be when
they come in one in five women in
England and Wales have experienced
stalking while four men the figure is
one in 10 the Suzy lamb blue trust is
named after the 25 year old estate agent
who went missing in 1986 and is presumed
murdered this is an additional tool
that's available for victims which is
great but you need to have an effective
trained police force behind it and other
professionals need to understand exactly
what this means if we're going to have
effective robot courts could use the new
ruling to force perpetrators to seek
professional help and urgent cases could
be fast-tracked it means others won't
have to go through the decade-long
ordeal Tracy suffered and the Brady Sky
News